cientos de personas se acercaron a la
iglesia cristiana de Mississippi
Boulevard para despedir a tairy Nichols
el protagonista del último caso de
violencia contra los afroamericanos en
Estados Unidos
hemos venido el primer día del mes de la
historia afroamericana
hemos venido en diferentes medios de
transporte a través de un clima y
condiciones viales traicioneros
transparencia total
responsabilidad y Reforma legislativa
integral
el homicidio de Nichols revivó
sentimientos de injusticia en la
comunidad afroestadounidense y llevó al
gobierno a tomar cartas en el asunto por
un lado la vicepresidenta kamala Harris
asistió al funeral de Nichols
este acto violento no buscaba la
seguridad pública no fue realizado para
mantener la seguridad pública
[Aplausos]
uno se tiene que preguntar si esto fuera
un interés para mantener la seguridad
pública tars Nichols debería estar aquí
hoy
no tenía él también derecho a estar
seguro Así que cuando hablamos de
seguridad pública entendamos lo que
significa en su forma
debería haber estado a salvo
por el otro la Casa Blanca anunció
reuniones con legisladores por el
proyecto de ley policial de George Floyd
este jueves el presidente recibirá el
representante y a un pequeño grupo de
miembros del congresión al Black Ops
aquí en la casa blanca para conversar
sobre la ley de justicia y policía de
George Floyd y otras políticas
compartidas
el proyecto tiene como objetivo de tener
las tácticas agresivas de aplicación de
la ley pero aún está pendiente por la
aprobación en el congreso